welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session
pioneering our understanding of the
human brain is my pleasure to introduce
to doctor Nutter Parata tun doctor
protein is an associate professor of
Neurosurgery and radiation oncology and
an affiliated faculty in bioengineering
and neuroscience at UCLA as a
neurosurgeon neuroscientist and
bioengineer he has the unique
perspective and training to integrate
these fields and take advantage of the
unparalleled opportunities presented by
neurosurgery to study human brain
function and design novel newer
technologies for complete biography of
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr. proteins talk is entitled early
feasibility study of a visual cortical
prosthesis for the blind the orion
visual prosthesis system my name is dr.
Veronica Shannon and I will be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
level seminar presented by lab rooms we
would like to extend our special thanks
to the brain initiative program
directors and in particular dr. James
math for their efforts in organizing
this session before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting your questions
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located at the
far left of your screen and type your
questions in the drop down box our
presenter will respond to your questions
by email following the presentation the
presentation is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without any further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. Nutter
Katya
hello I'm nadir Perrotti and from UCLA
neurosurgery thank you for this
opportunity to speak to you about our
early feasibility study of a visual
cortical prosthesis for the block blind
using the Orion visual prosthesis system
I'll start with some disclosures I have
been working with Second Sight on this
project of over the past six years have
had some grants support from them
and this is now a collaborative project
funded by the NIH I also do some
consulting work for other companies in
this space so I want to start with the
need why do we do this type of work 39
million people worldwide are legally
blind and much of that blindness is due
to unpreventable causes in terms of
treating blindness there is a lot of
work in terms of accessibility you know
with iPhones and other devices to
improve quality of life but in terms of
restoring vision there's really only one
device that is fda-approved
it happens to also have been created by
Second Sight which is the Argus system
which is a retinal prosthesis which
couples a glasses with video camera a
video processing unit and wireless
connection to an array that is implanted
on the back of the retina that is
approved for retinitis pigmentosa
there's some trials wrap a Julia macular
degeneration but really it's only for
people whose retina has some function
left and so it's generalizability is a
little bit more limited than we'd like
so the goal here is to develop a
cortical prosthesis for previously cited
patients in order to make sure the
visual cortex is developed who have know
or bear light perception of course
anytime you develop a new device there
are safety concerns first and foremost
you want to make sure you're helping
people and not hurting them so there's
implant related concerns or concerns
about seizures with cortical stimulation
we know that cortical stimulation can
induce seizures secondarily once we get
the safety concerns address there's
practical concerns you know can we is it
surgically practical to do this is it a
way that can be adopted widely and then
clinical utility you know what can
people see what can we help them see do
they have to see the way that we know
vision to be so I want to explore some
of these concepts putting it in a
historical context as well you know
we're not the first group nor will we
probably be the last group we do this
we're brinly and Lewin did a lot of work
in the past with chronic implants in
some patients being able to place an
array over the visual cortex in a
subdural with the subdural array mapping
out the visual space but unfortunately a
lot of their work was limited and much
of it wasn't published due to untimely
death and so there's still a lot of work
to be done again a lot of research is
also done in sighted patients and people
who have epilepsy who happens to have
arrays over the visual cortex this is
just one example from a group at
Stanford showing that there is a very
good prediction of the size of a
phosphine that can be elicited in a
sighted subject based on the current
density that might be delivered by a
electorate at any given spot I don't
want to get too much into that because I
want to get into the practicalities of
what can happen in a blinded subject
though so when we started this work one
of our initial preliminary studies was
actually in a blind subject we thought
we needed some chronic experience in a
patient who was blind we took an
off-the-shelf device which is the neuro
based responsive neurostimulation system
in a 30 year old patient with a history
of coronary Hirata syndrome in order to
see what she could see and how we can do
this chronically and how reliable this
might be we did systematic manipulations
and this has over ten months but we've
gone beyond that ten month period at
this point I want to share some of those
results in this subject because this was
off the shelf it was not purpose-built
for testing blindness or testing vision
in a blind subject with two electrical
photographic strips each with four
contacts we have eight contacts and here
you can see that each stimulation in
each contact was able to produce a
visual phosphine it's a different size
different shape different location for
every area that was stimulated and it
respected the horizontal Meridian as
we'd expect according to the calcarine
sulcus so this was
very encouraging with consistent
localization over time this is an
example of the shape and location of
percepts across sessions showing that
you know when we stimulate a certain
area across sessions they would see it
in the same or this particular subject
we see it in the same spot over a month
of testing so that consistency over time
though the lack of plasticity is
actually a good thing for developing a
visual cortical prosthesis
we also learned a lot about the
stimulation biology of the visual cortex
and this is something that came out you
know there's a lot of literature about
what it takes to activate neurons and
what we found was that the stimulation
parameters for fostering productions
shares two basic characteristics of the
strength duration curve and neuronal
excitation and again without getting
into too much detail I'll say that these
slides show that there's a real base
current or a minimum amplitude of
infinite pulse width frequency and that
is present so there's a sort of a
minimum current that must occur in order
to elicit a response or a phosphate
there's also again a minimum charge is
regarded to elicit a phosphate and the
extra charge increases linearly as the
pulse width or frequency increases and
those are illustrated here these are
very important concepts in terms of
determining how a chronic stimulation
system would have to be programmed and
adjust it perhaps the more important
slide is getting some insight into how
these phosphate perceptions are changed
by different stimulation parameters so
although you might think that it's total
current that affects how people perceive
a phosphate what we see here is that the
charge per trial is not what determines
the absolute intensity rather you can
see for example under a1 the dotted line
shows the perceived intensity of a
phosphine as the frequency is modulated
whereas the solid line shows the
perceived intensity as the amplitudes
modulator you can see that for the same
charge per trial an approximately
ten microcoulombs the perceived
intensity can be dramatically different
and we see that in almost every single
contact so it's not just charge that
we're interested in amplitude modulation
and frequency modulation can
differentially affect the patient's
perceptions with chronic visual
stimulation so this work was really
essential in providing us the motivation
to really charge forward with a
purpose-built visual prosthesis system
which is called Orion which leverages
the existing technology from Argos the
same idea of having an implanted array
wirelessly connected through an RF coil
with a video processing unit glasses
with a video camera
the advantage of visual cortical
prosthesis is it bypasses the optic
nerve goes directly to the visual cortex
we did some preclinical testing to prove
the safety of this implant in terms of
large animal studies to confirm that
there wasn't any adverse effect from the
implanted stimulation and then we of
course did the device the trial that I
just showed you with a chronic
stimulation with a non purpose-built
device this is were fortunately funded
by the brain initiative this shows
schematically what the implant looks
like and in the first panel you see the
glasses with an RF coil and a video
processing unit in the corner the two
brain schematics showed the roughly
triangular shaped array over the medial
occipital lobe with a cable and a skull
mounted array where we coupled two and
communicate with device this was based
on cadaveric large animal and
feasibility studies and at this point
using this device design we've implanted
six subjects across two sites and the
plan at this point is to follow these
six sites six subjects across the two
sites at UCLA and Baylor with the
neurosurgeon leading at Baylor being dr.
Danny oh sure with a primary outcome of
safety but secondary outcome of really
assessing the feasibility the ability to
produce phosphines long-term
functionality device and benefit in
terms of visual functioning functional
vision and quality of life this is an
example of what the implant looks like
it's a u-shaped incision there's a small
craniotomy seen in the middle panel
where the cable runs into the inner
hemispheric fissure where the array is
placed over the medial occipital lobe
you can see the device and the RF coil
to the left and that's the incision
there as with any technique we start a
little bit larger with our approach in
order to make sure feasibility
anticipate that this will get smaller
over time to date with the UCL a
subjects we have an average age of
implant of 51 female 3 males and the
causes of blindness are shown there
trauma pediatric blind as someone who
has a pediatric condition that evolves
into complete blindness and glaucoma and
that highlights really how this device
is potentially useful from multiple
diagnoses rather than Argos which is
currently only improved retinitis
pigmentosa implant duration the shortest
duration at this point is nine months
and we have someone who's implanted over
a year and we're very happy with the
results so far as I said safety is the
major issue and there has been one
serious adverse event which is a seizure
which has been resolved that's something
that was anticipated could be a problem
it's been in a single subject and we've
had four non serious adverse events as
well with hand twitching and a visual
aura as well as two events of headaches
and there's two patients who have had no
adverse events in three subjects with no
serious adverse events in the UCL a
cohort in terms of our thresholds this
is something that we need to understand
so we know how much power a device like
this needs to have thresholds are
determined based on being able to see a
phosphate 50% of the time you can see
the fossa
the average threshold is grinding around
two to two and a half million across
subjects and that has been consistent
over time and across contact as you can
in subject 156 out of the sixty contacts
are they able to elicit a phosphine 60
out of 60 in the second subject and 59
out of 59 and 59 59 in the third and
fourth subject showing very high
reliability of producing phosphenes so
we've done some preliminary studies in
light localization staring of screen
with a bright box where patients have to
point to the light and early testing has
been a very positive almost all of our
subjects are able to do that with high
reliability as well as direction of
motion testing more details will follow
as we analyze that data and presented in
subsequent presentations our research
focus in the first six months has really
been to establish the safety established
what our thresholds are and then create
video settings and establish simulation
safety setting so people can go home
with these devices we've cleared all of
our subjects at UCLA for home use so
they take at home and use it up to two
two hours a day to explore their home
and see how the device can be used
effectively we've also initiated
rehabilitation sessions so it's very
important to realize that these patients
aren't going to have normal vision
restored but they need to learn to adapt
to this new form of vision and it's not
to say that it's not useful but it's
something new in some ways you can
consider it like sensory substitution
and they need to learn how to use it and
identify the pathways to making it the
most effective therapy possible for them
one of the issues we've been focusing on
is this issue of spatial mapping you
know in the Argus 2 with a retinal
implant there was a one-to-one spatial
mapping meaning if you stimulate in a
pattern that looks like an age you would
anticipate that a patient would see in
the form of an H as we know the visual
cortex doesn't have that type of mapping
and so just because an array looks a
certain way stimulating a certain
pattern or an H as we see here in blue
dots on the array does not translate
into an H in the visual space because of
the organization of the visual cortex
this is an area of that we are studying
extensive
we're trying to understand how we should
do the spatial mapping in order to make
the device as useful as possible note
that I already said that the light
localization is very good direction
emotions have things already very good
so even without having a deep
understanding of the optimal way of
doing spatial map and we still have very
promising results but we need to develop
an algorithm for efficient and accurate
spatial mapping in order to make this
useful in one area we've looked at is
you know is from the imaging literature
we have a lot of information about how
polar angles are mapped in the visual
cortices as well as eccentricity is maps
individual cortices and here you can see
an Orion array with the white dots
overlaid in that area and one of the
questions is you know how reliably can
we predict where the phosphene will be
based on these population level maps are
these population level maps the best way
to map out the visual space and get the
device up and going or do we need
individualized maps as part of the
investigations that we're doing
currently to better refine the system
for home use I want to start closing out
my presentation with a couple examples
of real world use and patient
experiences that will help you really
understand what this is like for
patients I'll take some time to read
these these are feedback from the vision
rehab specialist it's the first one he
was able to find the cue ball with no
problems on the table and note that
these are patients who have no like
reception or bear-like perception I
wouldn't have been able to do this
before he's able to tell the cue ball
from the blue ten and also from the
balls with the stripe versus the cue
ball he could find the rack balls at the
other end of the table too here's
another example we found that looking
forward is where the Orion shines better
for the user as they can detect upcoming
objects he's able to see cars parked on
the side street openings in the sidewalk
up into driveways etc again so you know
the device is not the vision as we know
it but as a visual aid can be extremely
could be extremely useful especially if
integrated with other kinds of visual
aids the next one when working
throughout her apartment what sorry when
ya working through our apartment
she's able to tell where I was located
and when standing in front of a
ten-foot-wide light wall without digital
clutter she's also able to correctly
determine whether I was traveling from
left to right or right to left along
this well seven out of ten times again
pretty amazing considering these people
are have no light perception for the
most part finally he's able to order
patterns from small checkers big
checkers of white cloth there's a
half-inch difference and checker size in
the pattern so I think you know these
are very hard to quantify in clinical
trials were very focused on
quantification but the quantification
that we do in the clinic setting with
formal testing is not necessarily
representative real life and we think
these real life examples are really
where there is significant value and I
think what we're finding is the subjects
are finding success with Orion for
everyday tasks I will say that the the
amount of success is variable and not
every subject is able to use it the same
way it has to some extent to do with
expectation management so um I'll start
with you know what our what our
occlusion primary visual cortex
stimulation is feasible we've seen that
with our first patient we didn't have a
purpose-built device with the neuro pay
system and we're also seeing it with
early results from our feasibility study
here the simulation parameters are
predictable based on basic science
insights into the physiology of neuronal
excitation phosphenes are reproducible
to consistent over time we're now is
trying to trying to better understand
the modulation of these phosphenes
temporal factors so how quickly can you
stimulate to develop a constant
perception or if you want to develop a
flickering perception how what are the
temporal parameters we need to
understand a frame of reference and then
real-life applications some other issues
that I will just briefly talk about and
I've mentioned already these temporal
issues the flicker fusion experiments
are in our future that we need to do
spatial resolution issues you know how
do we need to make the array even more
precise or is this basically what we're
going to get how further work do we need
to do these are questions we need to
address I've talked about spatial
mapping the importance of rehabilitation
has become very clear over time
because if this is not a plug-and-play
solution it's a people need to learn
just like with any real ability
rehabilitative device how to use it
optimally and then this idea of sensory
substitution finally and there are
ethical issues with restoring some kind
of sensation or ability to patients as
well as the people who enroll these
trials and expectations they have and
there's something we need to consider
very carefully so I hope I've been able
to give you some insight into our work
in the visual cortical prosthesis thank
you for your time thank you for that
exciting talk on this cutting edge
technology dr. brought in as a reminder
our speaker will follow many questions
about his presentation by email next we
have dr. Michael Bushnell and his
colleague dr. John McNaughton he will be
giving another innovative presentation
on rave our analysis and visualization
of intracranial encephalography hope to
see you there